[Applause]
[Music]
big [ __ ] that's why I said anytime I
need a basket I want the broader go to
Carmela's he's gonna give it to begin
the evening and we talked a little bit
the big two hander the Knicks continue
to take it right to the Hawks who look
like they are a bit hungover when after
last night that jab step you got a step
back that's three straight offensive
rebounds and refuse by the day closing
seconds down to half a second
when Carmelo Anthony let that one go
[Applause]
hello a second time we'd like he's on a
trampoline nasty sassy stuff by Melo
looks like the [ __ ] by John the guys on
the bench at off the [ __ ] this is how
they've got to play the rest of the
season where Zynga's knocked it away
[Applause]
[Music]
timeout who knows it is not like to look
at the floor big seven hello sixty right
there gives up the baseline to be lady
the tip by Adams that was missing
earlier Sefolosha sent an excellent job
on Anthony Anthony now drives gets
[Applause]
baseline look so nice short twice
[Applause]
it appeared he was trying to get
[Applause]
no figures yelling foul
get up because why are you dropping off
you don't want him to take the three so
you get up on if you try to force it
inside
I must matched up with the rookie REO
his own young Jason Smith for to look at
it ruled a 2 on the floor but that's
three straight buckets for Carmelo
Anthony of the smaller and slower
platonovitch they don't want to use it
here
Anthony trying to clear up tip Gilchrist
on him Rose comes back
Anthony backs in turns puts it up
[Applause]
this time he wants the right side he's
got Wiggins on him single coverage
Anthony thinks puts up the jump Oh puck
sitting with 2.3 the dating Club mellow
it that he nails it
and the Knicks lead by two four four
four teams threw up an air ball just a
couple of shots ago with confidence
knocks down the big jumper and now the
Knicks need a stop Harris shoving the
ball stripped gets it back puts up an
off-balance shot so trying to change
that tonight right here beating the
clock dramatic finish
I would be the beneficiary know what's
going to quickly impeccable timing by
their Melo is second stuff of the game
today Millsap on him six seconds drives
inside he got hit and he tied the
ballgame up with 2.6 mark slap playing
smart where's the double-team look at
guys looking as he goes to do no
warrants coming over to contestant yeah
that was no SAP did that at New York in
that close game look at this look at the
Hawks though to come with a hope he
delivers the deuce and we're tied again
minutes in these last two save the day
for the moment yeah both they've come in
that same area Michael owning the beast
line with the follow a jumper Melo 7n1
because he lost his headband Hardaway
Macklin blocked it off his head right
there it didn't fall off on its own
muche right on top of them and Anthony
with a veteran play hey little knock it
down
Covington three seconds Carmelo shoot
does well-defended can't stop that beeps
a weapon in the game has ever seen yep
38,000 career for Meritage to fall down
on a crossover and the next back up by
21 game Melo Willie to deal in it